today on our show the Green Lantern
Corps
Wonder Woman Justice League and more on
today's episode a fat bang on Batman to
Malaga so I went for it
welcome back Batman I'm Batman Kevin I'm
Marvin Rd wow that would be you [ __ ]
started it man I was feeling it though
you started something go meow acting as
a matter of choices and I chose I chose
not to choose to let it go okay let's
talk about the news the big news big dog
they announced the other day when did
they announce this how did this happen a
couple days ago they announced and by
the day I mean one of brothers announced
that they were not giving up entirely on
Green Lantern we thought they might give
him that he's not in Justice League and
nobody spoken that name out loud in
quite a while since Ryan Reynolds 2011
yeah
but they're making easy costumes
changing costumes Sinestro letters a
litany of bad decisions that's just not
a bad decision the other the bad
decision was the cloud paradigm yeah but
even still like gotta say no air ducts
yeah yeah it's easily forgotten but who
announced this it was it hot in the
trades I think just that know where
they're like hey we're doing it I think
so I think that they were just like hey
by the way it's the new year and here's
the big first superhero movie news for
those who don't know we're talking about
they've announced a movie called the
Green Lantern Corps you need which was
kind of a described as a lethal weapon
in space hmm and if it's going to be
these weapon that means you need a white
guy and a black guy who's too old for
this [ __ ]
so then who well it would be reversed
here well no it would be still Hal
Jordan and Jung gandha Stewart but al
Jordan would be the grizzled old vet vs.
Jon Stewart as the new guy where do you
think they're gone vice versa they can
go vice versa Jon Stewart's the grizzled
will they'd the Danny Glover
and yeah so you can still get out Jordan
is the Mel Gibson with Martin Riggs yeah
Riggs in my club is Murtagh 4d flip the
equation and go
Hal Jordan is the season item tool to
the sugar control bishop and you know
the young guy is ready Jon Stewart well
they're doing that a little bit in the
training date TV series where the old
guy all that bill paxton is playing the
role that denzel washington plays good
fella can you imagine it's like you're
built you're Bill Paxton you're like who
played this before we did the Washington
plays this before
he's [ __ ] kidding me George we're
screwed
well done um yeah I saw him on a
billboard and I was like wow who's the
other guy
I was Ethan Hawke Ethan Hawke is a black
dude ha ha ha because I mean you still
have to key name of my high school punk
band Ethan Hawke is a black dude named
in a minimum and a minimum in the middle
reality I am usually amazing okay Green
Lantern Corps is happening yeah and it's
uh it's it's going to be algae orden
it's going to be Jon Stewart do you
think they use anything from I mean
they're not even talking about
acknowledging the other movie so that
means they have to introduce tomar uh
ray and [ __ ] Kilowog again I mean he
was always my dad I'll throw again and I
remember taking Olin power I might have
told you the story I took my son to see
Green Lantern when it came out him at
the time he was I was 12 so he whatever
math is gonna take seven or eight and he
was like I love this more of this dad it
makes sense no no that was not as it was
it was kind of basic it was so-so
Green Lantern is the hero right yes what
makes him the hero uh because he's the
guy on earth but there's like a thousand
other Green Lantern's
yeah and all better at it than he is
yeah so what why yeah so we care about
how Jordan is not good at it and also
Doc yellow I think we just found a real
fatal flaw in the ring
logic through if a kid can pull it apart
so yeah I've never been a fan of the
Green Lantern books for that reason like
I get it but you know you can build this
entire like military story in the cops
in outer space and all that stuff but if
your movies about your guy and everybody
else but your guy could do that job
better than he does but what makes your
guy special outer space cops were done
very well and going into the galaxy with
the Nova Corps and that's kind of just
the Green Lantern Corps for Marvel yeah
so it's doable
but also we didn't follow like getting
Nova Corps for the movie yeah they're
just named a guard down to him and call
him an [ __ ] and then about that I'm
I'm I'm danger pitiful because of the
you know Lethal Weapon in space angle
means they might have a sense of humor
about the thing right now looking for
comedy no just looking for a comic book
not looking for comics looking for comic
books thank you it is also entirely
possible that this in the wake of
Deadpool is the first film to actually
have been greenlit after Deadpool yeah
like hey throw a few jokes in a room on
Lily's webinar spaces that'd be funny in
this right we are funny and action and
adventure and people diving off roofs
and [ __ ] we can do that but so who is
the funny that they're bringing on board
to put this together David s Goyer oh is
there really a David's not known for
comedy but he is known for you know
universe building over there at Warner
Brothers he is your only Thai living tie
to Chris Nolan if you're not the Chris
Nolan hoarders brother or sister or the
other know the boy we don't talk about
either David's name is on the dark night
right it's on button begins and dark
night and doesn't
so from now until the end of time David
will always be at the top of the warm
brothers DC mu trough and you can't
[ __ ] argue it no and also even though
David did say about Martian Manhunter he
was like can't use a character it's in
outer space and silly and it's like wait
so you know these guys are in outer
space too right yeah well maybe not
maybe this time they're just going to be
on earth my look I got no beef as long
as David at while we're in the world of
Green Lantern Corps introduces little
Martian Manhunter in there I mean at
this point come on you have to let you
know what I'm saying
you could be be a boy boy do it
and Goyer also to his credit wrote the
first late movie which is amazing which
is amazing which ns opens with the
[ __ ] blood shower yeah yeah gets
passed for life that's pretty [ __ ]
amazing sequence yeah like that's bed
yeoman like work and all that blood and
all this [ __ ] mammoth fantastic
opening sequel it really is so yeah like
the gore all right give it a go again it
remember you wrote a movie a while back
called super max yeah the [ __ ] green
arrow in the prison movie yeah which one
a brother seemed very hot on in there
and yeah what the [ __ ] really here every
now and again just lobs went over the
fence we all member sayma made Dan money
right tomatoes don't make it Maggie I
spend a lot of money and king's ransom I
think I'll say he's writing with a fella
named Justin Rhodes who's that I'm not
familiar with his work but I think he's
one of those roads where we're going we
don't need any roads so Square and
Justin Rose was like I'd still like to
be involved uh yeah I think he's a sort
of having about a spec that everybody
loved he might have been on the
blacklist at some point but yes he's one
of others is hot on him they paired the
two together and they're wrong with it
uh-huh hey man whatever [ __ ] give me a
Green Lantern movie you and don't be
gun-shy and when I say gun I mean a
green gun made of my imagination my will
if you will the give me give me more
Green Lantern man
first if you don't succeed [ __ ] dry
try try try again
keep keep trying keep swinging take
another swing at bat take another swing
at the Batman they do it all the time
every couple of years where you going to
knock give us a new Green Lantern every
few years don't be afraid of that the
cool concept yeah she's got a magic ring
and make anything in his imagination
come true just begging you for once make
him at one point slip and you see two
people [ __ ] in space just like he's
like that citizen what are you doing how
put along like this all it's in my mind
today he's like this is that we're going
to be parallax parallax Sara knew not
paradoxes apparently parallax parallax
are you that's right what's like cloudy
parallax we're chase your yellow cloud
[ __ ] away with these [ __ ] green
people look at how much love there make
it parallax love cut reflector
conquering away my males married Blake
Lively right so it wasn't you know some
came out yeah that's lovely for them and
again and one of the greatest jokes and
Deadpool is like you know and don't make
my costume green human baby comes from
Ellen it does okay so that's happy news
in the DC Universe movie Kingdom over
there at Warner Brothers lately though
there's not been much happy news coming
out we've heard like Ben Affleck playing
footsie with the Batman movie now where
it's just like hey maybe it happens
maybe it doesn't mother doing that's
right not gonna do an onion dualism
right script a right I'm not put on the
back and a second brush it's a good one
now having worked with a guy known him
am I gonna do it another Magnum there's
only gonna tighten future Regan name I'm
not gonna let me write that all we want
to go by this well it is no I saw him
make a comment though in the press where
he was like you know people talked about
being asked about Batman he's like the
real pain me ass he said he used the
profane man because he said any time he
says anything it's used for clickbait
mmm-hmm so you know him saying like well
you know we're gonna get the script
right otherwise I'm gonna move forward
that gets turned into like that walking
away from the Batman it like but it's
like hey man
heavy is the head that wears the cowl
they don't pay you to be Batman
you know I'm saying Matty [ __ ] you do
free that's fun they pay it if I can put
up with all the questions about when you
make into that man because that's people
who are excited about a that character
be that you're the guy and playing the
character we all love that part of
Batman V Superman and see that the maker
of our goal is going to go make a
[ __ ] Batman so you got to understand
a Ben Affleck director or filmmakers
I've never met that you've you got
expectation - I yeah like all of his
[ __ ] that's what the moneys for yeah
that's what they so yeah there's a
little bit of like was that what's going
on because that was supposed to be
rolling for 2018 right yeah they wanted
that they were supposed to be shooting
this year because they've got a very
finely calibrated sort of runway for
films coming out on the LaBeouf that
seems to be thrown off kilter well now
they got Gotham City sirens or whatever
the Harley Quinn Catwoman they're
extending their universe and David Eyre
who air who has directed Suicide Squad
stuff he's going to go back up make
another flick up to bat rather yeah they
got Aquaman which is happening is that
movie : right now I change comm is I
think it is no I think that this piece
another echos yeah there's long I think
I did see some skills from set so now
I'm Justice League so you know from
Aquaman
no flash directory at them no flash
director knows cyborg director so yeah
seems like the the tail end of the
Justice League gene pool is not getting
quite a lot of love so there are two
movies coming in 2017 mark there are
Wonder Woman we've seen trailers for and
we're all very excited about and Justice
League which we've seen a trailer for
and we're all very excited about yes we
can't wait to see these movies we're in
the bag for these movies let's be honest
I you know they could be [ __ ] made
they can make these movies with
squirrels and I would still be like this
is fantastic
have you seen beady squirrel I'm amber I
am so you know I'm in the bag for these
flicks
that being said disturbing report is
distributed the force hit the Internet
today somebody heard that somebody might
have saw something that they were like I
don't know how I get
do you know the details I know the
details of this thing a newsman - I have
Doug to the bottom of this as it turns
out it did not require that much digging
because this map nd a journalist named
Sasha Perry waiver was on Collider video
Claude a video a lot of video talking
about a person that you know the source
she has who has seen the film was seeing
one woman and came out of it saying that
it has many of the problems that BBS had
in that the plot is somewhat incoherent
better somewhat disjointed and then it's
got some tonal issues now I meant why do
I instantly want to go make a downfall
video everyone leave the room right now
god dammit why now again let's stress
that this is a right I heard somebody
second this is fair enough now second co
you know cousin sauna 31 flavors right
totally it is a bit of a game of the
grapevine
I know Sasha very well I don't believe
she's making it up but again you you is
the integrity of the journalist is not
for question for me like I know where I
would trust her but I don't know who she
talked to where I don't know the taste
of the person she talked to you I don't
know what version of the film this
person saw but all of those things are
still AWOL and these are the big
question there would be questions and
without or I will submit who why
questions at all after rogue one
remember how much [ __ ] horseshit we
were fed for a year about like it's got
problems
oh they got problems all this road one
movie is gonna lose so much money
oh my god they're thinking before slaves
oh [ __ ] this movie is gonna blow oh my
god they kept problem they brought in
another film ago my god and look how
amazing that movie is yeah I mean these
at this point in January he's not coming
until May they could they could reshoot
half the movies they wanted to do
they're not going to but they're always
reshoot so many things they're only test
screenings are always second pentene yes
maybe the reports are [ __ ] untrue
they could be pro now or like you said
like the person who told the person you
trust you don't know what that person's
taste is maybe like you know like you
know having ham it's I can't it's just
two species you shouldn't even be really
talking about but we should address it
at least as a news story because the
show is called famine but but just like
it's there's something out there but
it's not conclusive there's no evidence
and it's not like someone's lying but
it's don't get worried yet no I mean
like at some point we will see this
movie then well then we'll work I will
let you know we will probably see this
movie before you guys see this movie and
when we do then we can say fewer words
some emotions wouldn't a non-spoilery
way because we believe in your sanctity
of the viewing experience but still at
this point it's very premature you say
it would not hold up disjointed is the
word that I thought I saw thrown around
Clayton yeah disjointed they said you
know then there was also a little bit of
shade thrown at Justice League as well
not that I saw in that particular report
but it would not also surprised I saw
different somebody said something about
leg and Justice League I heard dr. right
I you know let me meaning it besides
what the internet wants to believe and
let me tell you something ain't showing
anybody these [ __ ] movies yet that's
not like a hundred percent rock-solid
keeping their [ __ ] mouth shut you
know what I'm saying I mean at some
point in the next month or so they're
going to be test screenings in places
like I wouldn't bet on him and I don't
know I wouldn't honestly would a movie
that big and like you know for reasons
like that and [ __ ] where people are just
like I've heard bla bla bla I wouldn't
be surprised as Marvel test their movies
I honestly don't know I mean most people
do I don't know about these comic book
movies there's too much riding on David
testo one mm-hmm I mean what brothers
did test um he shut them down and just
rode one over that I think time
mom it's time he's smart about something
well they sure did intense where one did
they mark there you go what they did
test since that's one to thank ya it
doesn't do so it's going to get made
there was why why would they test that
because they weren't sure and so they
tested it and that's how you get that's
how you got there's two different cuts
memory last I'd heard that there was
like you know they said hey we got a cut
we'd like to show you I didn't know that
they tested they said they tested Boca
because the both cups and the cut from
air scored lower than the cut from the
trailer house yeah trailer house put
like a rock and roll music in there and
they spent to the wazoo on clearances
and they may be kind of poppy and so
then they decided all right well let's
merge these two trucks together because
the stories will bit stronger here but
there's a little more energy there all
of that comes in to test screenings Wow
and were there any reports do they do
that anymore then cool news ever do the
like you know somebody snuck into it I
don't know what they do this so much
anymore
um how they keep it quiet it's hard I
mean they test [ __ ] up in Chatsworth
near where where I live all the time
like people in Chatsworth have the
internet I know it's also right now
federal Los Angeles yeah you know like I
don't know how to keep the [ __ ] quiet I
don't know
I wouldn't test it anymore I'd like a
[ __ ] tested on the lot with like
employees like you know and ganas once I
could be who aren't afraid to do like
that's dog [ __ ] right give it to me I'll
watch it I'll tell you what I think I
you would never get a good opinion out
of me I'm like oh I got my job and
coming alive so I'm not discerning I
have no discerning taste whatsoever I'm
all about the discerning taste I just
wanna listen to me yeah he's the guy she
shows you do honestly you're the person
I would show [ __ ] here are the nine
things that you could fix tomorrow he's
smart with story and [ __ ] like that but
they won't ever show it to me no no all
right though you guys have fun you got
meanwhile I'm here to approve all
screening
I love these [ __ ] movies even when
they get them wrong they're doing them
right that's what I think the class
sample all right 100 all the [ __ ]
news we're doing for this show it's all
DC Warner Brothers run dude
and the news is this no news you know
what I'm saying yes everything's fine
relax Wonder Woman's not broken Justice
League's fine we nobody knows what we
don't know anything man this is all fake
news which apparently the thing that
exists now oh my god welcome to 2017
here we go for fat man I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith and I am Mark Barnard
doing the next episode we'll talk about
some other [ __ ] same bat-time same
bat-channel spawn Capcom or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Music]